hey y'all it's undercat here and this
tire tuesday video we're actually not
going to
analyze this week's data set we actually
already did analyze this data set which
is the palmer penguins data set
where we actually created a dashboard
instead i think it'd be interesting to
kind of do a shorter video and kind of
go over the gg animate package
which is an extension to the gg plot 2
package
which basically creates um animated
charts
so um thomas what's his name uh
thomas peterson created this uh package
it's a really cool package and it's
actually a pretty simple one
uh i actually don't know i don't really
use a lot of anime charts in my
day-to-day analyses
um however i think um animated charts
are really good
for a lot of like data journalism style
stuff i think they can add a lot of
impact
to your uh to your storytelling with
data however actual analysis
i'm not sure how much value it adds to
uh some like data science related
projects
but um one of the most classic examples
of animated charts to use
as a storytelling device is the uh
it's this famous chart where it shows
like um the progression of life
expectancy
to gdp per capita for each continent i
believe there's a really popular uh
like a ted talk on it but i think it'd
be interesting to kind of look at
on this pro publica data set which is
about ni
nypd um civilian complaints against new
york city police officers
i actually requested the data set and i
have it already so
we're just going to open it up into our
uh
our files so i'm going to go here
go to my tidy tuesday repo and then set
that as my working directory
um i'm going to open up ar markdown file
and i'm going to call this tidy tuesday
animated uh chart
animated charts okay cool
i'm gonna pop this up and we're gonna
um do that
so let's actually load in the tidy verse
the gg animate
package and we're also going to load up
the gif key
which is like the rendering engine to it
finally i'm going to do the uh
read.csv police allocations.csv
okay so if we actually look at our
df we can see that each row represents
one complaint against one police officer
so unique mls
id is the police officer's name um if i
actually go
on to my uh um
um uh was it free tuesday folder we have
a kind of a
data explanation so we can kind of refer
to that too
oops so we have the layout which is like
the
uni which like a little um data
dictionary
we have some abbreviations of the
explanations
command um abbreviations
fatal which is kind of like the on what
the
officers are being accused of and we
also have dispositions
which to me i think the is a pretty
important thing
so for example if we look at um
substantiated it means
that the alleged conduct violated the
rules
exonerated means the alleged conduct
occurred but did not violate the rules
and then unsubstantiated means
it was investigated but could not
conclude that they broke the rules
so when i look at this um i think really
substantiated and exonerated
are basically pretty bad because we
don't want police officers to have
any truth in their allegations of
misconduct
unsubstantiated is the best case
scenario
okay so let's do this um one thing that
i thought would be interesting
you just kind of look at the actual um
time series of the uh
of the actual allegations so what we can
do is we can just do
a select and we can do say
let's say year received so it was a year
received
and what else do we want um how about we
do
a fado type
and what else should we do so we have
like the allegation or fredo type
um and then we let's do the actual
outcome or
let's say maybe board disposition since
that that way we can look at the
substantiated unsubstantiated exonerated
okay so we have that i think i'm going
to do um
just a slight renaming so fatal type
we'll just say the allegation
and board that's just disposition is the
result
okay cool so one thing that i think
would be good is to change
these things into just like kind of like
the results of it
right so i'm going to do a mutate and
say result
equals and since i want to do a bunch of
if statements to basically change like
substantiate will mean this
unsubstantiated will mean this
accelerated means
this so i'm just going to use a case
when statement
which is a very useful um way to
do a multiple if else statements in a
digestible manner
so what we're going to do is we're going
to say str
detect result
and the pattern is we'll say
substantiated
i'm just going to copy this
substantiated
if that's true it means that there
technically was a violation
so we'll say violation um additionally
we'll
do another one and say result and then
we'll say
exonerated
and when if we look at our data table
right we can see that exonerate means
the alleged conduct occurred
but did not violate so that means what
the
allegation the allegation did happen but
did not violate any of the rules so
we're
gonna still call that a violation
right and then we can also do it and
then finally we can say
true or else we'll say no uh
no violation right so we have that
changed
okay so what else can we do
um we can do like a basic count of like
the allegations
okay or the phatotypes so we can see the
count of it so we'll
let's say uh group by year received
and we'll say count allegation by result
right then we'll say an ungroup
so what this shows us is like okay so if
we do a little arrange
by year received allegation
and result we can see that
so there were three um
abusive authority allegations that
resulted in no violation right
so we can see kind of the result and the
total amount of uh
accusations made okay
so what we want to do now is actually
make a plot of this so we can say like
okay we'll do a ggplot
received um let's say y equals n
and we'll say color equals i don't know
um
allegation or gm line
and maybe do a facet wrap and we'll just
compare the
violations and no violations right so
we'll say
result uh
let's say scales equals free y
year received let's see your ear
okay so we have that maybe we'll throw
in the
theme legend position equals top
right so we have the allegation we can
see um
how no violations have been increasing
and also violations have been increasing
for
for all of it in addition we can see how
2020 dips
that's because probably um not all of
2020 has been fully completed
okay so that's pretty interesting right
um
so how do we make this into an actual uh
i guess animated chart so what we just
have to do is we can do this and we can
add
a um transition
so if we go to our gg animate package
um we can see that most of it just
relies on transition states
so it's just extending your plot and
adding transitions and specifying how
you want to make those transitions
so in this case we actually want to
transition by year because i want to
reveal
like the result of these plots okay
so i'm going to do this i'm going to say
transition oops
transition uh reveal this case we'll say
year receive
right because we kind of want to go
throughout the year and see like oh wow
there's a huge
increase on just overall allegations and
we can see how both violations and no
violations have kind of increased
um together okay so we have year
received and that's basically it
so let's make this into a uh
violation ts
right so i'm actually going to paste
this right here
so we can kind of have this uh other
thing going on
okay and what's the df review okay okay
so once we have our violation ts
what we what we need to do now is just
use the animate function
and give it the violation ts and we can
say that renderer
in this case i think the default is this
type of renderer
um however you can also convert this
into instead of rendering as a gif
you can render it as like an mp4
okay so it's going to start animating
the chart
and we can see it kind of continuing
like that
okay and now you can see the frames are
loading up
and now it says final encoding done and
you may be wondering like where is
our animated chart well if we look over
here
uh we can see i'm moving
right you can see how it's it's it's
being shown the time series and we see
it increasing and boom
right pretty cool chart um we can also
add
um just some cool little things like uh
um what's here we can also add a uh i'm
gonna
um a gm point so if we do gm point
it'll show us the um the chart
with a little point that'll kind of
follow along
and as you can see all these charts do
take a long time to actually develop
or render out i'm not sure
how what's the best way to make it to
increase the rendering
but it's still pretty fun and it's
pretty easy to implement
so you can see how it's kind of like you
can see the leading line that's a little
uh point which is really nice to see
cool so we can also do more like um
um we can also kind of extend it to
other things so
instead of doing transition reveal what
if we want to do like more of a time
series so if we go here maybe they'll
show it
um so they show different transition
states is there a transition time
example okay not really
but what we can do now is kind of look
at some other stuff
so what if we want to look at the each
year's
uh or maybe yeah each year's
um result of the allegations right
so let's do that so let's do df i will
say
select uh
board disposition and year received
cool i'm actually going to add the same
thing that we added right here
um which actually i might just you know
what i'm gonna
hmm yeah i'm just gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna actually assign it just that
so i'm gonna do that and say df
boom uh do you have mutate
let's see your result oh it's cause uh
result it's not result
it's uh was it um
board disposition uh
we'll say boom look at that
okay so now we have a result so now we
can do is select
uh result and year received
right and what another thing that i want
to do is
um which is count year received
and result cool
and then we can do maybe like a ggplot x
equals result
y equals n fill equals
result that's gm
calm cool
um hmm
yeah yeah let's do that and then we can
just do a uh
we can do a uh what let's see here let's
say uh we don't really need a
legend so let's say theme
legend.position
equals none
okay finally we can add a transition
so in this time oops what in this case i
want to just do a time
series um which this this plot this plot
right here violation was actually doing
that
um beforehand it's basically showing a
time series however it's not
showing um the difference in time
um where it's not making the new chart
each different time it's just kind of
doing a reveal through the time
um i'll kind of show you it right now it
looks a little bit different
in this case we want to look at each
year's um
violation and no violation change
on a bar chart okay so let's do that so
transition
time and we'll say year received
oops year year received
okay and we'll say um
disposition result
then what we can do now is just do it
animate disposition
result renderer uh gif ski
renderer and let's see what it looks
like let's see how it changes
okay so you can see how it's kind of
increasing but we kind of have a huge
problem with this
for one we can see how you know
violations both no vibration and
violation
is increasing but we kind of don't know
which year it is
luckily um gg animate actually comes
with
um some functions to put into
um your your label so if we say labs
or labels and we say title and we'll say
year
and then what we can do now is just use
the glue syntax which is basically like
a pseudo variable
so in this case um
each each little frame or each plot
represents one frame
and so since we're using transition time
i'm going to say
a frame time okay so let's just send
this let's just render it again
okay and now we can see how the year is
changing
um and how overall like we can see oh
okay like maybe in
2014 2016 there's more violations than
uh no violations from the result
great so when i was also looking at this
data
um we kind of find we found out that
there was actually some
uh precinct data because for each
officer
um an officer is serving is serving a
precinct
so i thought it'd be interesting to kind
of look at it by precinct right
so let's do that let's say select uh
precinct
um the officer in this case the best way
to select the officer i think is the
unique
mls id which is kind of like the
identifier for like first name last name
command
now and stuff like that and let's do
the fader type okay
and what i want to kind of look at
is i want to look at um kind of the
distribution for each precinct's
officer complaints and what i mean by
that is like okay
for each each precinct what is the
average amount of complaints
per officer right that'd be kind of
interesting we could see like oh maybe
maybe one precinct has way more
complaints than the other
other precincts and what we can do now
is we can just say like
group by precinct
and we can say count unique most
oh it unique most id for each officer
we want to count how many allegations
they have for each fatal type
okay so in this case in precinct zero um
this
officer had one
accusation of abusive authority okay
so now what we can do is we can just do
ungroup
and what we can do is just a simple gg
plot where we'll say like you know
x equals n uh fill equals equals fatal
type plus gm calm
uh oops gm gm one way stop gm histogram
right and we can see how most officers
are only
getting uh for each each officer in a
precinct
most allegations are only once it's not
it's almost you just a one-time deal
they only have one complaint against
them um throughout i guess
this these this decade these like years
of um
uh nypd police reports which is kind of
a good thing
in a perfect sense we would have zero
but obviously this is just only showing
ones
who have allegations but we can see that
okay so now we have this what i kind of
want to do is let's say uh
theme legend dot position
equals uh equals top
so we have that and you know i i'm
kind of interested we could do a facet
wrap too we could say like facet
rap by fado type skills equals
free y right maybe do that that'd be
kind of interesting to see that and then
maybe we could just say
none and we can see the difference in uh
we can see the difference in uh
distributions for all four of them
okay maybe i'll add a plus scale
x log 10 see what that looks like
sure that that looks kind of interesting
maybe maybe even like a scale
x square root
right okay maybe i don't know
we'll figure out okay now i'm going to
do a transition
and since what i want to do is i want to
go by precinct we can just say
the precinct isn't necessarily an event
because it's kind of like
almost a categorical variable so instead
what we're going to do is transition
states so she's going to cycle through
each precinct and make a new plot
okay so in this case we're going to say
oh
precinct and what we can do now is we
can add in our labs
so labs and we'll say title
equals precinct and then we can do our
thing
and for our transition states it
actually kind of goes in and out
so it doesn't just kind of do a quick
quick click of like a discrete variable
and actually kind of does like a
continuous style
so what we're going to say is we're
going to do a closest
closest state so
one thing that i get confused about a
lot is like
the actual glue syntax so in this case
we're just doing closest state
nothing too crazy what else can we put
into this
plot um oh yeah for our transition
states
um we can actually customize
the transitional length oops come on
the transition length and the state
length
so what i was seeing is he he uh
for most of the examples they actually
just say like transition
length is two state length is one
just so it's a little bit smoother um
you can also change it where
you know each precinct is shown for a
longer time and transitions faster
it's kind of up to the visualization and
depending how many states you're going
to go through
so i'm going to make this plot first um
precinct uh distribution right
cool and then let's do a animate and say
precinct
distribution renderer is gif ski
uh oops renderer
cool let's have it run
and it's going to take well because it's
essentially making a lot of
images of the plots and then kind of
like doing a flipbook of it you know
it's going through each frame and
plotting it out
okay and you can see how the precincts
are changing
um they're showing it out but one thing
that i i
see here right is it's kind of choppy
it's not as pretty as say
um i say let's hear as this one right
where it it's it's kind of doing a nice
transition it's not as
clunky you know so we can actually do
now is we can um add in
enter fade and exit shrink
so that's what i'm going to do so i'm
going to say plus enter
fade plus exit shrink
okay and then i do ctrl shift enter and
i'll animate it again
so let's see it kind of go on i actually
really like this plot i think it's
really interesting to just see how you
can see how
these precincts obviously have an effect
on
um just the amount of complaints and
that could just mean um there's more
population
there might be more crimes um there's a
lot of other factors into it but just
interesting to look at how
not all precincts are created equal
additionally i think it'd be interesting
interesting to see you know what
discrepancies do some precincts have
okay
so i guess yeah okay so
it's kind of going through i guess the
uh the bar chart
really doesn't do well with that fade in
and the shrink
we might have to actually increase the
uh transition length and stuff like that
but i think we should go on to one last
plot
um this plot i found to be pretty
interesting
when i was looking at the data so for
example
um we also have the rank
of the officer during the incident so i
think that'd be kind of interesting to
look at so let's do that so let's say
rank of the incident uh maybe year
received
and then um let's do uh
hmm and then the result result
okay so what i want to see is our our
say if we look at our rankings so let's
just say uh
select rank of the incident
distinct i'm curious is i wonder if
say police officers are more likely to
have more uh
are more likely to be uh
to have allegations sent to them that
are true
opposed to say a captain or a lieutenant
right
so let's see what that let's see if
there's any type of relationship that we
can look at
um so let's do that and what we can do
is just do a simple count
so uh group by year oops
you're received and say count
uh rank incident and the result so for
each year
we're gonna count for every year we're
going to count each ranks
um violations or result violations right
so we're going to do a ungroup arrange
by say year is
oops your receipt rank
incident and result right so we can see
like okay
1985. how many violations how many
violations how many non-violations
or or came out of it okay
additionally i kind of want to look at
the total results
total allegations right maybe we want to
control for that
so we can also say mutate and say total
total allegations equals sum of
n right so total allocation sum of n
and then we can do a ungroup and do that
so once you have that um what else can
we do
um
let's let's compare let's see here let's
compare
the violations the yeah let's
compare the violations and no violations
for each incident and go
through it by year but what i want to do
is kind of control
for the total allegations right so let's
see how we're going to do this
actually won't do that so then i'll say
uh mutate
and i'll say mutate n equals n divided
by total
allegations right so now it's
it's more normalized um and then what we
can do
is then ungroup it great
um actually maybe yeah we'll say
i gotta i got an idea i'll say n equals
n divide by some n or
we'll say uh we'll say uh uh prep
proportion or say prop
or p of our
uh p
results there we go
so that way that way it's a little bit
cleaner and then we'll say
um count and then we'll say
name equals no that's fine that's fine
sorry about that okay so if i wanted to
compare
the results the no violation of
violations for each officer
given the p results i'm going to do a
pivot wider so i'm going to say pivot
wider names from is result
and values from equals p
results right
okay ooh actually i got an idea
maybe i i can't use that then you can
see how these things i want these to be
on the same
row so what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna i'm gonna deselect n so
select minus n
select minus n and now we'll do that
there we go
okay interesting
actually why i'm gonna i wanna do some
validation right now
so
okay we have those
okay so violations no violations etc
um okay
what i'm confused about right now is let
me see if i'm grouped by
okay i i need to also group by
um or was it rank of the incident
i think
there we go
yep there we go okay
and then we can do a select minus n
and there we go okay sorry about that i
i saw that um
one of the proportions weren't lining up
okay so we can see how there's some nas
and we can say
um was it that values fill
equals zero and i'll fill it up with
zero and now what we can do is ggplot
aes x equals uh uh
no violation y equals violation color
equals rank of the incident
and maybe just do a gm point
hmm actually maybe i'm gonna flip it up
i'm gonna flip it so
violation
no violation violation
ah
okay and then we'll do a plus gm
point plus was a scale
x reverse there we go
one there we go
plus scale y reverse
i think that's is that what we want
no no we don't okay
hmm you know when i'm looking at this
plot
um i think it might be easier to just
have it
on a frequency basis so just set
however we can actually look at it so we
can just do a um
transition in this case i want to do it
just by time
right so i'm going to transition time in
this case i'll say year received
plus um i don't know uh was it labs and
we'll say
uh title equals year
frame time
okay and we'll say rank allegations
and we'll just look at this plot so
we'll say animate
rank allegations
was it renderer gif ski
render okay
okay yep i don't want i don't like to do
this okay so i'm gonna actually do that
instead okay so
instead of doing the proportion i'm
actually gonna do
this so we'll save n
and let's see what it looks like right
so we have violation no violations
i think i think this will look much
better
so let's let's see what that looks like
see how it's kind of like it's going off
uh back and forth because i kind of
normalized it
and honestly it doesn't look good in a
in this type of line it might be better
to be actually on
on a horizontal line but i think just
having the nut with the frequency
approach is a little bit better
so we can see how it's moving one thing
that i think would be good
is that if we add in geom
a b line and say uh slope equals one
intercept equals zero
um that way we can kind of put in a plot
where basically
the slope will be right here and we want
the points to be below
the the line because that means that all
the majority of their allegations
resulted in no violation so i'm gonna do
that you know
so say subtitle equals
points below the line means
means um
majority of allegations
were false
points above the line
means majority of allegations were
true okay i think that i think that's a
i think that's a smart idea and then
what we
also can do is we can say a size equals
like 12.
um and i'm gonna put this thing under
there just so the points can be above
the line
okay let's see what that looks like
and you can see how police are are kind
of just
rising in violations and all all of them
are going
above the line it's pretty cool uh
it's a little sad but it's pretty
interesting so one thing that i want to
do is i want to
maybe change it a little bit so i'll say
uh color
equals uh let's say color equals
off we'll just remove the the color um
title in addition what we can do is we
kind of add
in see how these things are moving but
we kind of don't know where its previous
location is it's just kind of
running everywhere we can also add in
this thing called
shadow wake so shadow wake
wake length equals we'll say 0.1
alpha equals false and this will just
add kind of like a reference
little tail so let's run this again and
we'll call it a day
oops and i'm gonna actually show you um
what it's creating for the
tuesday thing um sometimes when you
render it
um it'll kind of put it into a temporary
folder of just like uh images
and you kind of have to be careful about
it okay so now what we can see here
is that see how this you can see a
little tail or kind of residual
um patterns you can see where it's kind
of going for its trajectories
that can be pretty useful
so you see points below the line means
majority of oops
means or
means majority of algae's your fault
yeah there you go so that was basically
it
i know this is kind of a quick um simple
video but
i thought it'd be kind of fun to kind of
go over these cool little
animated charts i know they're really
popular on reddit and they're pretty
easy to make and
extend the gt plot universe i think for
future videos i think it might work on
more
extensions to ggplot2 and kind of focus
a lot on data visualizations
so with that being said i'll see you
guys next week and tidy on